can you just hold the cotton off for me
first covid now monkey pox the nhs is
once again in a race against a virus
this is one of 18 clinics in london
alone now offering a vaccine against the
disease as cases continue to rise the
problem is many people don't know about
the symptoms and the symptoms are very
general like any other flu you know so
the confusion is a lot so i mean when i
got the chance and i asked them i was
lucky enough to get it done
for now only those considered at high
risk of exposure are being contacted to
come forward for a jab it's mostly gay
bisexual and other men who have sex with
men as they make up the majority of
cases daniel said he jumped at the
chance but will still change his
behavior in light of the outbreak most
probably i'll meet less people and i'll
try to protect myself more and
that's pretty much just like the covet
cases when you stay more at home i guess
and
you're not going on dates or
something else
symptoms are generally mild but they can
be severe haroon was in intensive care
for 10 days unable to swallow for
blisters in his throat he believes
action should have been taken sooner
this happened in the early stages of hiv
and aids you know people blamed gay
community for it until it was understood
that it wasn't a gay disease this really
boils my blood in a personal level
because we don't learn lessons from the
past so you think it hasn't been taken
seriously enough until now no i don't
think so the pace of the vaccine rollout
has also been criticized with 10 weeks
now passed since the first case was
identified the speed of the rollout
depends on how many of these the nhs has
doses of the vaccine more than a hundred
thousand extra have just been ordered
but to put that into context this trust
alone has identified more than 25 000
people who are at high risk so clearly
those extra doses won't last very long
chelsea and westminster foundation trust
has been given the most doses in the uk
but even here doctors fear they could
rapidly run out
we were initially given 4 000 doses of
vaccine we've already given out 1500 in
two weeks and that's just as we were
starting to ramp up our efforts it is a
massive source of concern for us that we
are going to over promise and under
deliver and we don't want to be given
out vaccine appointments if we can't
ensure that we've actually got the
vaccine available to give
those administering the jab are calling
for more funding and support if they are
to stop monkey pox becoming endemic in
the uk iva bennett sky news